[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
autour de quatre invités comment vivrons
nous dans quinze ans c'est la question
que nous poserons à alexandra rosetti la
mère de voisins-le-bretonneux qui
lancent l'opération voisins
2035 grande consultation près de 900
habitants tirés au sort de sa ville marc
quelle ville nous aurons d'ici 15 ans
c'est la question que nous lui poserons
avec vincent couronne fondateur des
surligneurs et enseignant à lui vécu
nous parlerons de l'europe et de la
façon dont il est traité peut-être mal
traités dans cette campagne pour les
élections présidentielles nous prendrons
aussi des des nouvelles de rima yadir et
my à 10 et la championne de france de
boxe elle prépare activement le
championnat d'europe qui aura lieu le 19
février prochain au mur ou mais tout de
suite on va parler de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique avec jean-paul
vanderlinden jean paul van der linden et
et économistes et les spécialistes de
l'économie de l'environnement et on va
parler avec lui d'un film qui a eu un
grand succès qui s'abattent d'hôtes look
up qui raconte l'arrivée d'une météorite
sur la terre et qui d'une sorte de
métaphore de la surdité ou de
l'aveuglément des pouvoirs publics et
des gouvernants sur le réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]
jean-paul vanderlinden bonjour bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes professeur en études
de l'environnement et vous êtes banque
de l'observatoire du climat de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
l'un de vos domaines de recherche c'est
l'adaptation des zones côtières au
changement climatique
on en parle un petit peu mais on va
d'abord commencer par un parent and un
film qui fait un gros succès sur sur
netflix et que vous avez regardé avec
avec certains scientifiques notamment
des membres du giec c'est c'est le film
qui s'appelle don't look up je rappelle
très vite y raconte la découverte par
deux scientifiques eux interprété par
jennifer lawrence et des odeurs d'ozil
caprio d'une comète qui fonce droit sur
la terre et mbeki risque de provoquer la
fin du monde en gros et est ce que pour
vous comme on l'a dit ce film est une
sorte de métaphore de ce qui se passe
pour le réchauffement climatique
concernant ma réponse sera en deux temps
d'abord effectivement ça nous rappelle
par analogie l'extrême frustration qu'à
la communauté scientifique face à à
l'allaitement c'est pour le changement
climatique et le fait que cette alerte
ne soit pas entendue donc là il ya
clairement une analogie à faire mais
après quand on va dans les détails c'est
un peu moins convaincant je trouve
on peut penser à différentes choses
d'abord la nature du risque existentiel
en question une comète et le changement
climatique c'est quand même très
différent dans un cas l'humanité et
appelé à souffrir longtemps dans l'autre
cas à l'humanité disparaît d'un coup en
un éclair c'est très différent au niveau
2 de l'effet sur sur notre conception de
qui nous sommes en tant qu'humanité mais
aussi en termes de politiques publiques
donc là il ya quand même quelque chose
de très différent mais la frustration
reste tirer une sonnette d'alarmé basée
sur des arguments rationnels et ne pas
être entendu quelque chose d'assez
interpellant effectivement mais vous le
voulez vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs dans
un interview vous aviez donné au fonds
aux fins d'en dans le film là la fin du
monde vivent un mois de la météorite que
du dysfonctionnement des institutions
est ce que c'était et vous qui aviez dit
ça et est ce que on pourrait dire aussi
ça de la question du réchauffement c'est
à dire qu'il ya en effet cette surdité
peut-être il ya une réalité qui est
celle que les scientifiques des mots
très peut-être d'une sorte de surdité et
d'aveuglément par rapport à ça oui alors
c'est une question très importante quand
on pense à l'enclos coeur parce que donc
l'opep met le doigt le caricaturalement
à la fois sur le fait que parfois nos
élus sont décevant tel cas aux
etats-unis des derniers mandats et c'est
le cas dans le film on a l'impression
que l'aspiration et clairement tirée du
dernier mandat aux états unis
n'est fondamentalement on a eu d'autres
présidents aux etats-unis et la crise
climatique elle est toujours en cours
donc il ya quelque chose sur la capacité
qu'ont nos institutions
apercevoir le signal je vais dire d'un
accident dans le temps long à la crise
environnementale s'inscrit dans le temps
long pas dans le temps court
contrairement à à la comète dans le film
et dans le temps long au travers des
cycles électoraux on a des alternances
on a beaucoup de choses qui se passent
et pourtant cette question qui touche
les collectifs dans son essence la plus
fondamentale sa survie et des nos
institutions n'arrive pas à me capturer
le signal et je pense qu'on a le droit
de se poser des questions sur comment
faire pour améliorer les choses lui
justement peut-être parce qu'il ya ce
temps long et et que le pouvoir
politique a peut-être le bol le nez rivé
sur les sondages sur les prochaines
échéances électorales
il a du mal à réaliser la réalité pied
il ya toujours cette idée de on verra
bien demain où les autres verront vient
après nous peut-être
une vraie question on dit parfois que le
pouvoir politique s'inscrit à la fois
dans un cycle électoral mais aussi dans
un cycle matériel plus qu'un site le
mans classic le moral c'est à dire qu'il
faut arriver à subvenir aux besoins de
sa population il faut arriver à fournir
de l'emploi s'assurer que toute une
série de choses soient remplies avant de
se soucier de questions plus
fondamentales comme notre survie alors
aligner un site électorale avec le cycle
long comme le cycle du changement
climatique c'est possible il ya beaucoup
de choses pour lesquelles on s'est
inscrit dans le temps long ça fait quand
même longtemps qu'il n'ya plus guère en
euros il n'y a pas eu besoin d'attendre
une série de sites de quatre ans pour
qu'une paix européenne s'installe de
façon durable et donc il n'ya pas
impossibilité street mais il faut que la
menace soit perçue et il faut que des
engagements soit fort et aujourd'hui
quelles que soient nos élus on a
l'impression que la menace n'est pas
suffisamment perçu
qu'elle est quel est alors le sentiment
peut être psychique ou psychologique qui
est celui des chercheurs canton quand on
voit là on a une réalité qui effaça doué
qui est indéniable qui est incontestable
même si elle a été plus être contestée
tendance dans le passé un
oeil à quoi un peu de 2,2 de désespoir
un peu de colère
je crois bien qu'on puisse parler de
désespoir et colère ne travaux s'inscrit
dans un métier qui nous passionne et il
n'a pas nous désespérer ou en tout cas
contraire pas pour ou contre les sports
mais qu'on fait pour accéder à une
certaine forme de réalité robuste non je
pense qu'il ya une certaine incrédulité
d'abord une incrédulité car cela nous
semble tellement évident que l'on se dit
qu'on ne comprend pas bien et puis une
fois cette incrédulité
dépassé eh bien on s'engage on s'engage
à la fois scientifiquement en produisant
des données de plus en plus robuste et
d'information de plus en plus précises
mais on s'engage aussi sur un front qui
ressemble aux politiques mais qui ne
relèvent pas de la politique dans le
quotidien tels que la pratique nos
politiciens mais qui se relève dans
l'administration de la cité de notre
collectif les quilles et de ne pas se
reposer avant que c'est ses
connaissances qui nous sont accessibles
soit accessible à tous et toutes
l'actrice du des cancers liés à la fumée
de cigarette je pense illustre ça très
bien il n'y a pas eu de désespoir
personne n'a abandonné la sonnette
d'alarmé a été tirée retirer jusqu'à ce
que ce soit entendue et donc je pense
que pour pour les chercheurs il ya cette
incrédulité était un grand d'entêtement
et d'ailleurs les climatologues bien
entendu vrai il ya ya ya aussi peut-être
oui une sorte de deux ans de refus de
voir les choses parfois de certains des
jours alors on le voit dans des looks
dans d'autres trucs un peu la présidente
qui est jouée par berry triplette assez
caricatural mais mais même je lisais bad
et des chercheurs que vous connaissez
bien qui sont les chercheurs du giec
sont un peu se disent quand même il ya
finalement assez peu de responsables
politiques qui ont lui même le rapport
de l'europe le nom rapport quand les
rapports du giec
ça ça pose une question fondamentale qui
est au coeur des recherches de
laboratoire que que je le bonheur de
diriger c'est comment les gens font pour
avoir une attitude à l'égard du monde et
en fait ce sont des choix complexe où la
connaissance ne suffit pas on a besoin
aussi d'être sécurisé et matériellement
on a besoin aussi d'être sécurisé et
moralement est dans une période de
transition cette sécurité là on la perd
je parle de transition énergétique
transition environnementale
ce qui nous émerveille avant devient
moins émerveillant je pense aux trente
glorieuses je pense au moteur à
explosion
je pense que beaucoup de gens de ma
génération ont grandi avec une
admiration joyeuse du moteur à explosion
aujourd'hui nous devons bien admettre
que le même objet est dangereux mais
bien c'est un changement qui prend du
temps et qui peut effectivement donner
envie de faire l'autruche pendant un
temps parce que nous perdons une de nos
sources de confort matériel parce que
nous perdons une de nos sources de joie
mais cette paire ne doit pas être vu
comme un deuil mais plutôt comme comme
un court assez normal la connaissance
progresse un temps au fumet aujourd'hui
on ne fume plus un temps nous émettions
du co2 aujourd'hui nous allons faire un
effort pour ne plus en maîtres je pense
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
c'est aussi un changement qui demande
qui demandait une adhésion aussi de
l'opinion
justement il ya actuellement la campagne
présidentielle on parle finalement assez
peu d'aidé des questions
environnementales de ce problème du
changement climatique on parle par
exemple beaucoup de l'immigration mais
on ne dit pas qu une des grandes causes
de l'immigration dans les années fut dur
ça va être justement
le réchauffement climatique
alors là on touche à un second volet de
la question vous m'aviez posé
initialement sur le dysfonctionnement de
nos institutions les les agendas ne sont
pas seulement le produit de ce qu'ils
aiment et c'est aussi le produit de ce
que des groupes d'intérêts souhaite
mettre en avant
aujourd'hui on est bien obligé de se
rendre compte que la question
environnementale les questions
climatiques en tant que tel nous avons
de la peine à la mettre à l'avant des
agendas est ce parce que cela menace des
intérêts plus trop du pouvoir que c'est
possible et d'ex futurs élus comme des
zébus je ne n'ai pas de deux semaines
question partisane ou simplement y at il
des disques plus accessible plus qui
résonne mieux dans les médias et les
médias font partie de nos institutions
ça fait partie des institutions dont je
souhaite la protection bien entendu
mais effectivement on aimerait que la
question environnementale on s'en
saisissent directement
et qu'on ne soit pas obligé de la
prendre indirectement avec des objets
qui en fait beaucoup moins menaçants
pour nous et notre avenir c'est vrai que
vous avez raison sur les médias je
lisais une phase d'un chercheur
justement qu'il disait gamin c'était son
rapport avec des journalistes qui
j'aurais utilisé par vous avez peut-être
réseau sur le réchauffement climatique
mais enfin c'est pas très sexy
oui effectivement yahia cette question
bordeaux glisse est aussi où
effectivement les acteurs sont beaucoup
plus élégant que nous sommes d'habitude
et etc c'est une vraie question cette
question de de l'intérêt mais mais la
crise migratoire pour autant qu'il y en
ait une n'est pas sexy non plus donc il
ya vraiment quelque chose qui me touche
du collectif qui touchent des intérêts
qui nous demande mais bien de penser le
monde tel qu'il est et d'accepter de
l'affronter il ya alors non je disais
d'un nouveau domaine de recherche cette
adaptation du changement climatique dans
les zones côtières alors il ya il ya une
réalité qu'il a vu la montée des océans
puis on a vu des des épisodes comme le
comme le comme la tempête xynthia par
exemple ce qui vous intéresse vous si
j'ai bien compris c'est un peu la
réaction aussi des gens qui habitent
dans ces dans ces zones est et qui
parfois sont aussi dans le drôle dans le
déni et on peut les comprendre aussi
enfin pour comprendre parfois leurs
réactions
une série de travaux qui nous montre à
travers des entretiens avec des victimes
d'inondations ou des victimes
potentielles d'inondations que la
question d'inondation est une question
beaucoup plus complexes que le simple
fait de se faire envahir par de l'eau
c'est une question sur qui nous sommes
par rapport au monde qui nous entoure
mais c'est aussi une question sur nos
droits le droit à une retraite paisible
au bord de la mer qui est un droit que
nous avons tous je crois revendiquer
deux revendiquent encore une retraite
paisible
et si cette retraite c'est à dire ce qui
est supposé couronner des années
productive au service des autres et au
service de la production de richesse
collective et bien si cette retraitée
menacé par un environnement extérieur il
peut sembler naturel il est encore
semble en tout cas naturel aux gens que
nous rencontrons de considérer que c'est
une non-information que l'information
qui domine est une espèce de du moral
qui est leur paie
pendant ses années de leur vie c'est un
exemple un autre exemple c'est des gens
qui ont placé leur argent à la côte pour
qu'y perdre n'est pas n'est pas
compréhensible perdre pour pour des
événements qui leur sont extérieurs et
souvent les gens vont interpeller en
disant mais ces gens sont ils à wingles
demande-t-il non il ils ont comme tout
le monde un arbitrage entre différentes
réalités contradictoires et parfois il y
en a une qui passe à la trappe et je
pense qu'on doit apprendre à prêter
attention à ces réalités qu'ils passent
à la trappe et je vais terminer en
disant ceci nous chercheurs souvent nous
faisons passer la morale et d'économie à
la trappe mais tirons la sonnette
d'alarmé mais nous oublions qui lie à
d'autres volets et bien d'autres gens
oublient qu'il y à ce climat qui change
et qui nous menace parce que d'autres
réalités sont prioritaires et donc
l'idée d'engager une conversation pour
essayer de sortir du puits de choses
dont on ignore l'importance c'est bien à
cet arbitrage d'ailleurs que que nous
même tout va tous les individus que nous
sommes nous sommes confrontés tous les
jours justement avec avec cet épisode du
changement climatique comme comme vous
l'avez prouvé alors plus plus
pratiquement sûr sur les zones côtières
merci infiniment
jeunes accueillis aujourd'hui c'est très
agréable
et alors vous et puis si on a l'occasion
je gère un grand plaisir à vos invités
surtout sur ce plateau merci infiniment
[Musique]
alexandra rosetti bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la mère de voisins-le-bretonneux et
vous lancer une grande opération qui
s'appelle voisin 2035 une opération sur
ce que deviendra votre votre ville et
plus généralement nous environnement
dans une quinzaine d'années alors
peut-être d'abord pourquoi cette
opération et comment va-t-elle se
dérouler
alors l'idée c'est de d'impliquer les
habitants voisins
devenir de leur commune et cette idée
est née des changes qu'on a pu avoir
avec une association qui s'appelle sens
civique qui s'est créée un voisin suite
au grand débat national et le but de
cette association justement c'est
d'associer les habitants sur diverses
thématiques et nous de notre côté on
voit la ville se développer
sur différents assauts différents
aspects et
on a envie un petit peu de partager
l'avenir de la commune avec les avec les
citoyens et c'est comme ça que tu es née
l'idée d'avoir un projet à d'envergure
on va dire avec cette association pour
pouvoir consulter les habitants
et je pense qu'elle va permettre aussi
aux habitants de découvrir leur ville
sous un autre jour oui alors je crois
qu'il va y avoir 900 habitants 1 qui
vont être consultées noms qui vont
commencer à travailler dès le mois de
février sur 7 sur cette constatation
c'est évidemment c'est important
d'associer là population à ce que peut
être l'avenir d'une ville
tout à fait alors c'est 900 habitants
qu'on a tiré au sort pour sur les listes
électorales sachant que les 900 me
répondront pas positivement on s'en
doute bien mais c'est évidemment ouvert
à tous c'est à dire ce ne sont pas que
les habitants tirés au sort le tirage au
sort c'était une façon d'essayer
d'impliquer des gens qui peut être
n'aurait pas eu l'idée de venir par eux
mêmes parce que bah ils travaillent la
journée on rentre le soir on n'est pas
forcément dans l'actualité de sa commune
et donc c'était d'aller chercher des
gens qu'on n'a peut-être pas trop
l'habitude de voir
et mais bien sûr tout le monde que ce
soit vous conseiller de quartier ou
n'importe quel habitant est tout à fait
le bienvenu pour venir se projeter avec
nous dans l'avenir de la commune comment
vous vous l'imaginez vous votre ville
dont dont 15 ans vous avez déjà vu une
idée ce que j'ai presque y aura encore
des voitures est ce qu'il y aura encore
des grandes surfaces est-ce qu'il faut
imaginer des choses très très différente
de ce qui est aujourd'hui je me souviens
mois quand on imagine des blancs 2000
dans les années 60 on voyait des gens
qui volaient partout et aida ça jamais
est telle que habillé en cosmonaute
jamais été le cas est-ce que c'est des
évolutions très marquante ou à ce que ce
sera plutôt lente à votre avis
je pense qu'elle va être lente forcément
mais mais c'est vrai que la place de la
voiture est un vrai sujet et j'imagine
que elle va forcément évoluer alors je
ne suis pas jusqu'au-boutistes comme
comme la maire de paris évidemment mais
je pense qu'avec le temps puisqu'on veut
développer l'électrique c'est des choses
qui sont amenés à évoluer et puis on a
aussi nos usages actuels qui peuvent
également évoluer donc je pense à nos
centres commerciaux qui aujourd'hui sont
sont quant à elles ont une existence on
a une des nappes de parking voilà donc
on a peut-être des évolutions qui se
feront aussi dans ce cadre là mais je
pense que ce sont vraiment des aliments
des évolutions sur le long terme on
pourrait se poser la question de
pourquoi 15 ans parce que 15 ans a pour
paraître très long il ya des gens qui
disent bas c'est trop loin mais sauf que
tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui aura
forcément un impact sur l'avenir donc
quand on organise une commune quand on
fait des constructions basses et une
fois qu'on a construit on sait que cet
endroit là il y aura plus de possibilité
de changer les choses donc c'est
important d'y penser aujourd'hui pour
voir quelle ville quel type de villes et
villages centre ville on peut avoir
besoin demandez ça ne concerne pas que
le centre est ville évidemment ce qu'on
peut imaginer évidemment enfin on l'a
déjà c'est qu'on va aller dans un monde
de plus en plus portés sur le numérique
on parle déjà d'une bêta verbe ce monde
virtuel qui va peut-être arriver donc le
numérique c'est très important et en
même temps il ya peut-être dans la cause
de ceux du mérite la une un risque de
repli sur soi est ce qu'il faudra
prévoir peut-être des lieux où on pourra
se rencontrent et où on pourra parler
les uns avec les autres j'ai pas si
encore il y aura des bistrots mai mais
peut-être quand même des bious on peut
juste convivialité c'est important alors
moi j'imagine pas une ville dans 15 ans
en lieu de convivialité je pense que le
numérique a du bon mais peut être aussi
effectivement empêcher les gens de se
voir et c'est très très mauvais alors le
numérique nous a été très utile pendant
la crise
ça on ne peut pas le nier ça a permis de
garder le contact avec les habitants
c'était absolument essentiel maintenant
je ne conçois pas moi une ville où on ne
garde pas ses espaces de rencontre et de
convivialité
et c'est vrai que
le bistrot c'est où ça fait aussi partie
de notre façon de vivre on en a quelques
arbres voisins qui fonctionne bien donc
c'est comment essayer de préserver tout
ce tissu aussi commerçants alors je sais
que lévis ynwa rêve d'un marché ça c'est
un sujet qui date voilà donc pour avoir
un marché il faut d'abord avoir un lieu
adéquat ce qu'on n'a pas vraiment
aujourd'hui puisqu'on a étudié la
question puis après c'est d'autres modes
de travail mais mais voilà ça c'est un
exemple je pense que ça sortira mais
évidemment pour avoir un marché il faut
avoir un lieu vraiment adéquat puisque
il faut que les commerçants aient envie
de venir et de revenir régulièrement
donc voilà donc ça c'est des sujets mais
la convivialité pour moi à mon sens ça
est un objectif majeur des années à
venir cela dit vous êtes plutôt vous en
écoutant que quant aux propositions pour
l'instant est ce que dans les 900
habitants tirés au sort des deux voisins
qui vont participer à cette grande
consultation et skip de ronde et des
contacts s'étaient pas avec des
architectes avec l'urbaniste kiki au
corps à savoir justement sur les
constructions sur l'avs les matériaux
qu'on utilise sur la façon de 2,2 de
prévoir les les constructions les
habitations demain alors je pense que
tout est ouvert en tout cas du côté de
l'association puisque c'est elle qui
pilote et qui va proposer des choses
très diverses ce soit des marches
exploratoires
on peut travailler sur la ville de 1 km
on va travailler sur des ateliers l'idée
aussi
que nous ayons un temps peut-être au
nous puissions nous est lui aussi voir
les habitants parce que nous avons
beaucoup de contraintes c'est aussi une
difficulté c'est à dire qu'il ya la
ville idéale
qu'on peut on peut imaginer il ya aussi
toutes les contraintes qui nous viennent
de l'extérieur avec lesquels il faut
arriver à
jongler si je puis dire et nous ce que
nous essayons de faire c'est de se dire
pour bao qui on nous impose des choses
la loi le préfet l'état etc et comment
on en fait une opportunité pour notre
notre commune
d'avoir
un avenir je dirais qu'ils correspondent
à un petit peu à tout ce dont on a envie
aujourd'hui donc je pense que tout est
ouvert du côté de l'association en tout
cas et pourquoi pas effectivement c'est
une excellente idée fait rencontrer des
personnes spécialisées dans différents
domaines qu'il n'y a pas que des
histoires de construction on a on a
aussi les espaces verts on voit bien
d'ailleurs que ce week-end en a planté
le premier arbre d'un verger
participatif à la fonderie sur les bords
du lac nous avons également de
l'écopâturage mobile de notre côté donc
on voit bien que déjà de toute façon il
y à des évolutions
qui existe il ya une chose qui est assez
formidable quand on parle de l'avenir
comme ça et là vous avez 900
habitants de deux voisins qui sont tirés
au sort donc il ya des gens qui sont vos
partisans d'autres types sont peut-être
pas c'est que quand on parle de sade et
des grands problèmes de demain aux
fossettes dépasse les aider les clivages
politiques c'est ça c est ca réuni au
fond la population autour d'un projet
exactement on a envie de porter un récit
mais un récit qui soit le plus partagé
possible après on ne mettra pas tout le
monde d'accord c'était villans mais je
moi il me semble que il faut que les
gens soient éclairés aussi sur ce qui
est possible de faire pas possible de
faire et pour quelles raisons et puis
l'idée aussi de ce projet c'est de de
faire revenir les gens sûrs mais aussi
parce que les citoyens on le voit on
parle beaucoup de l'abstention et je
pense que les citoyens ils ont besoin de
reprendre confiance dans leurs élus et
de voir que leur avis compte et donc sur
un travail comme ça on voit la scène
aussi ré intéresser des habitants à la
chose publique
certes il habite dans la commune peut
être qu'il n'y travaillent pas ils
partent le matin ils rentrent le soir
mais la commune c'est quand même on l'a
vu avec cette crise c'est quand même le
lieu on va pouvoir se ressourcer et
trouver de l'aide de l'accompagnement et
du soutien c'était une façon de leur
montrer qu'ils ont au fond une influence
à pouvoir sur le sur leur propre vie il
ya cette consultation qui commence en
février ça ça jusqu'à quand elle aura
lieu et quoi ça va ça va au bout de tir
au fond donc elle a lieu jusqu'au mois
de juin donc voilà avec des différents
modes de consultation
et puis l'association ensuite dans ses
livrables doit donner le cahier qui
donnera toutes les propositions les
idées des attentes des habitants et puis
construire un récit un récit pro
communal on va dire puisqu'on parle
beaucoup de la notion de récits en ce
moment au niveau national mais nous on a
envie d'avoir notre petit récit à nous
aussi de comment cette villa peut encore
évoluer dans quel sens d'une initiative
est tout à fait passionnante revin qu'on
va suivre jeu on fera peut-être le point
de tout un tas s'il en est d'accord
merci beaucoup alexandre heures aux eti
et bravo pour ce pour ce projet
s'appelle donc voisin 2035 merci merci à
vous
[Musique]
vincent couronne bonjour
bonjour patrice vous êtes fondateur des
surligneurs vous enseigner à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vous êtes aussi un grand spécialiste de
l'europe et je voulais justement qu'on
aborde avec vous la question de l'europe
la façon dont elle est traitée ou
peut-être mal traités dont la campagne
présidentielle avec la france vient de
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne et on attend toujours un
petit peu les mêmes arguments selon sur
laquelle sûrs et une allégeance de la
france à l'exécutif communautaire on
entendu par exemple eric zemmour dire de
de bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie des finances qui dépeint un
employé de la commission européenne
c'est assez nouveau ce genre d'arguments
ou est ce que ce sont des poncifs pour
répète depuis longtemps
bon c'est pas très nouveau ce genre
d'arguments en fait c'est pas très
nouveau parce que il y a de manière
générale une méconnaissance du
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes par la classe politique
française et là-dessus eric zemmour ne
fait pas exception et puis il ya aussi
il faut dire un une incompréhension
entre les français et la construction
européenne et français ils veulent une
europe française qui fonctionne comme la
france est évidemment dans laquelle la
france est puissante mais le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes c'est justement essayer de
d'équilibrer les puissances en europe et
puis en plus de ça il y à une quelque
chose qui brouille un peu les pistes
c'est le conseil c'est à dire que cette
institution dans l'union qui ressemble
une sorte de sénat qui représente les
états et dans lequel le ministre bruno
le maire notamment siège et dans lequel
il prend des décisions mais il est
prompt à bruxelles avec ses partenaires
et quand il rentre en france il peut
très bien dire comme les autres
gouvernements par le passé ont pu le
faire c'est pas moi c'est bruxelles est
donc cette confusion sur qui prend
vraiment les décisions en europe alors
qu'en réalité la france à un quasi droit
de veto sur tout ce qui se passe dans
l'union européenne
l'ajustement quand on dit par exemple on
attaque beaucoup la commission
européenne va faire peut-être un petit
focus juridique mais on attaque beaucoup
la commission européenne en disant voilà
cette instance qui n'est pas
démocratique c'est de la technocratie
c'est eux qui prennent les décisions est
ce que c'est la commission qui prend les
décisions justement
alors ça dépend de quel type de décision
on parle en réalité le vrai pouvoir
politique dont l'union européenne il est
au sein du pouvoir législatif
c'est-à-dire le parlement européen et le
conseil qui représente les états la
commission elle elle ne fait qu'exécuter
en quelque sorte ce que et bien
vote comme acte législatif le parlement
et le conseil donc oui la commission
européenne a beaucoup de pouvoir parce
que c'est le pouvoir exécutif de l'union
comme un gouvernement en quelque sorte
mais elle est sous le contrôle étroit 1
du parlement européen et des états et
d'ailleurs même lorsque la commission
européenne prend des décisions pour
exécuter les lois européennes et bien
même là elle est sous le contrôle des
états qui vont l'aider à rédiger même
ses directives ses règlements et c'est
donc dire que la commission européenne a
tous les pouvoirs ou que en plus de ça
les non élus c'est pas vrai parce
qu'elle est bien élu par le parlement
européen
c'est faux en réalité parce que à la
fois il ya une responsabilité
démocratique devant le parlement
européen est aussi un contrôle très
étroit la part de l'état et d'ailleurs
on peut dire
sans dévoiler de secrets d'état que par
exemple emmanuel macron à a beaucoup
vrai pour la pour la pour la
numérisation de demain devant des riads
comme comme présidente de la commission
1 exactement et ce qui montre bien
l'influencé des états sur le sur le
fonctionnement de la commission
européenne et ça c'était en plus un
épisode qui montrait une sorte de lutte
entre les états et le parlement européen
puisque normalement c'est le parlement
européen qui devait décider de qui
serait le président aulas président de
la commission européenne les états n'ont
pas voulu ainsi cette fois ci est
effectivement sous l'influencé emmanuel
macron ils ont imposé une seule à van
der leyen mais en contrepartie le
parlement européen a imposé son
programme politique avec sur la van der
leyen donc elle n'a pas les mains libres
van der leyen elle doit mettre en oeuvre
le programme est bien conclu par les
différents partis politiques au
parlement européen alors il ya aussi une
sorte de contradiction qui peut être un
peu difficile à expliquer mais sur
laquelle on pourrait revenir c'est qu'au
fond la france qui est un des fondateurs
de l'europe et puis qu à la présidence a
actuellement de l'union européenne elle
l'a plutôt un statut privilégié au sein
au sein de l'europe et
bizarrement on dit toujours ah oui mais
la france subit l'europe alors que elle
en profite plutôt aux faux
oui elle en profite elle en profite
largement à alors on dit souvent qu'elle
est contributrice nette la frontière
qu'elle donne plus au budget d'union
qu'elle ne reçoit est en réalité la
simple présence de la france marché
intérieur européen lui fait gagner
énormément en termes de croissance en
termes d'euros de rentrées d'impôt etc
pour preuve même des états qui sont pas
membres de l'union européenne et qui
demande avoir accès au marché intérieur
payent pour avoir accès au marché
intérieur ce qui montre bien que c'est
rentable et puis ensuite il y a aussi le
fait que la france dans les attributions
l'union vu son poids notamment
démographiques comme je disais tout à
l'heure elle a quasiment un droit de
veto alors formellement un droit de veto
sur toutes les décisions mais mais
quasiment rien ne se fait dans l'union
européenne sans l'aval de la france au
sans son assentiment au moins tacite
ces dix dernières années typiquement la
france n'a opposé son veto à une
décision prise au sein de l'union
européenne qu'à trois reprises à sur les
sur les centaines les centaines d'actes
législatifs qui ont été adoptées ce qui
montre bien que encore une fois la
france elle a un poids quand même dans
l'union européenne et donc si l'union
européenne fait quelque chose la france
n'est en général pas pourquoi pas pour
rien alors il ya des problèmes qu'on
n'aborde pas trop dans cette campagne
présidentielle existons pourtant
essentielle c'est notamment la place de
l'europe dans le monde on le voit avec
le conflit russo ukrainien
elle n'est pas très présente et est ce
que est ce que l'idée d'une europe
puissante d'une puissance pardon est une
idée qu'il faut exclure ou qui pourrait
devenir un jour
alors je sais pas si elle pourrait
advenir ou s'il faut l'exclure mais en
tout état de cause c'est la voie que
difficilement l'union européenne est en
train de prendre sir l'europe puissance
alors que pendant des années elle s'y
résigne s comment dire elle s'y refuse
et
notamment sous influence de l'allemagne
qui ne voulait pas d'une europe
puissance mais les arguments de la
france et notamment sous l'effet des
manuels macron a beaucoup la france
l'allemagne pardon à avancer sur cette
question là et désormais union
européenne assume le fait de vouloir
construire une europe puissance ne sais
pas ce qu'ils en vouloir encore faut-il
sont les moyens notamment des moyens
budgétaires des moyens institutionnels
des moyens de coercition
et cela on n'y est pas encore et
notamment en matière de défense
alors il ya un débat qui divise quand
même l'europe on l'a vu avec la les
positions de la pologne et de la hongrie
notamment sur l'indépendance de la
justice et sur l'état de droit c'est le
débat sur au fond les valeurs de
l'europe et c'est le reproche que font
notamment la hongrie et la pologne l
europe au fonds de dépasser ses
compétences qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de
ce débat il ya battant oui ah oui mais
là c'est un départ en fait qui est vital
pour pour l'union européenne
actuellement c'est à dire que de l'issue
de ce débat
sortira en fait on décidera l'issue de
ce débat décidera de l'avenir même de
l'union européenne l'union européenne
n'est pas en danger en tant que tel par
dan ans le cas de ce débat là mais sa
nature demain c'est à dire est ce que
l'union européenne peut intervenir sur
les questions des valeurs sur les
questions de protection de la démocratie
par exemple d'indépendance de la justice
de lutte contre la corruption au sein
des états où est ce que les états
restent libres en fait de
d'utiliser l'argent de l'union
européenne sans avoir à rendre de
comptes et ça c'est clairement ce qui va
soit si on penche du côté du contrôle
par l'union européenne ce que font les
états pencher vers plus un système
fédéral ou au contraire si l'union
européenne recule sur ces sujets là
l'union européenne reviendrait peut-être
vers plus quelque chose d'international
et donc ça veut dire que derrière il
faut abandonner tout un tas de choses
hein leur puissance la construction
d'une défense commune etc qui du coup ne
pourrait pas voir le jour avec une
europe à l'image de ce que voudrait la
pologne c'est peut-être le vrai débat bd
des mois et des années qui viennent une
dernière question peut-être comment
n'explique pas ce que vous l'expliqué
sur le sur le plan économique forbes
c'est assez simple enfin on est toujours
plus fort a plusieurs que tout seul
comment comment expliquer quand même
sept
veaux vos goûts cette vague de
souverainisme qui fait croire qu'on
serait mieux si on était tout seul que
ni
je pense que il y a là aussi une
difficile difficulté à comprendre ce que
veulent véritablement les citoyens en
europe parce que on a parlé pendant la
pandémie à la fois de dunes d'un retour
de la protection de l'état aussi de
l'importance de la souveraineté de
l'état et en même temps on a parlé aussi
on le voit dans cette étude opinion de
manière très claire une montée en
puissance de un besoin de protection de
l'europe voire même aujourd'hui le
discours d'une souveraineté européenne
qui s'impose de plus en plus donc c'est
sur ces deux tableaux en réalité le
débat avance ce qui en réalité se se
passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a un
besoin de manière générale de plus de
souveraineté qu'elle soit nationale ou
européenne
les citoyens quand on regarde les études
d'opinion les enquêtes veulent
simplement plus de protection alors
qu'elle soit au niveau national ou
européen ça c'est encore un autre débat
mais ce qui est certain c'est que du
point de vue purement français on à la
difficulté à penser le pouvoir politique
à plusieurs niveaux c'est à dire que que
l'on puisse avoir une puissance
politique nationale qui est
super pole des avec une puissance
politique européenne on a du mal à
partager le pouvoir doit imaginer que
pouvoir puisse être partagée tout
simplement parce qu'on s'est construit
depuis le 19e siècle selon l'idée que la
nation et l'état nation notamment
étaient l'alpha et l'oméga de la
politique alors que des allemandes par
exemple ou même des italiens en des
systèmes beaucoup plus souple est
beaucoup plus partagée interne aux
souverainetés et envisage la france a
une vision très franco centre et est
très puissance du pouvoir alors que
l'europe elle a vocation à comment dire
à diminuer cette puissance et en
construire une plus plus vaste et plus
large donc c'est une question de réflexe
après derrière vous savez peut-être
implique un peu complexe à ce que
j'explique ici question de flex de
savoir si dans le débat public quand il
ya un problème est-ce qu'on se réfugie
dans l'état où est ce qu'au contraire on
demande plus de plus d'europe les deux
en réalité arrive et c'est un débat en
cours et sera tranchée forcément il est
petit à petit tranché pour faire mesure
des années merci à philippe vincent code
je sais que l'estuaire lignières vont
publier bientôt un livre il est il est
consacré à quoi il est consacré à
l'immigration et donc c'est sûr les
politiques et l'immigration tout ce que
c'est nos chers politiques disent comme
promesses impossibles à tenir en matière
d'immigration ou erreur qu'ils font
quand dans leurs discours nous on les a
sur lignon les a vérifiés et on contrôle
aussi des programmes pour les candidats
à l'élection présidentielle en matière
de migration pouvoir ce qui est possible
ou pas de faire et ben on en parlera ici
même merci beaucoup vincent couronne
[Musique]
rimaye a dit bonjour bonjour pas crif
alors vous êtes championne de france de
boxe vous avez le titre wba des super
plumes et vous préparer activement parce
que cette 19 février prochain aux
mureaux votre championnat d'europe
c'est bien ça
et alors là c'est là c'est
l'entraînement c'est dur là actuellement
inscrits va là c'est très intense on
s'entraîne tous les matins tous les
soirs donc ces cinq heures
d'entraînement par jour deux fois par
jour enfin deux heures et demie le matin
des amis le soir donc je suis assez
fatigué mais c'est tout à fait normal je
dirais que c'est de la bonne pratique il
paraît que vous vous dites que juste
avant les matches mais c'est peut-être
plus proche du 19 février où vous nous
enlevons alimenter presque partout le
manger très très peu pour perdre du
poids c'est pour être au bon poids ce
combat là où c'est pour la forme
c'est pour respecter la pesée donc
chaque boxeur doit respecter sa
catégorie de poids et au gramme près
sinon ça passera à 100 grammes au dessus
donc c'est pour ça que le boxeur de
semaine avant une semaine avant il et il
est en train de faire un régime
drastique
après ça dépend l'hygiène de vie de
certains mais en tout cas moi je
les derniers jours j'ai ri mange pas
beaucoup d'accord vous connaissez votre
adversaire
je regarde jamais le nom de mes
adversaires
par exemple et cc le boulou de votre
entraîneur ça c'est ça c'est le boulot
dabadie la lahb de d'enquêté de regarder
le style de la boxeuse et de faire le
travail en fonction et donc là il fait
le travail sans vous dire au fond elle
est elle à tell tale tels atouts tels
points forts tel point faible vous
travaillez sans trop savoir fins et
je comprends j'analyse en fonction de ce
qu'on fait mais j'ai pas tellement envie
de voir ce qu'elle fait comment elle
boxe j'ai pas envie de me polluer
l'esprit avec
si elle a trop de qualités j'ai pas
envie de d'être impressionné s'ils
allaient pas si forte j'ai pas non plus
envie là sous-estimée à cause d'une
vidéo donc je m'en occupe pas alors on
disait là on est dans la vous êtes dans
la phase d'entraînement intense ça se
passe ça se passe comment en gros une
journée de de rim ayadi aujourd'hui
matin le réveil directement la pesée
pour voir où j'en suis tous les matins
je me pèse ensuite un petit déjeuner
assez léger ensuite je file à
l'entraînement donc deux heures et demie
d'entraînement basé sur la technique et
l'apprentissage de la boxe aussi du
circuit training beaucoup de physique de
musculation le ensuite je rentre
déjeuner je fais la sieste et ensuite je
repars à l'entraînement en fin
d'après-midi pour pour faire du sparring
donc des combats et de la mise de grands
pour me tester quoi alors enfin trahir
de secret mais c'est vrai que vous avez
vous allez attraper comme beaucoup de
gens le lot micro de l'alcool le coc
vide évidemment cesser sa fatigue
kouakou kouakou quoi qu'on dise
ça y est là si vous êtes vous est remise
de santé en pleine forme effectivement
j'ai attrapé qu'ovide ça m'a vraiment
fatiguée pendant quatre cinq jours au
lit avec des courbatures de la fièvre et
puis je suis tout de suite repartir au
boulot dès que j'étais plus contagieuse
donc les trois premiers jours de reprise
ont été difficiles puis ensuite tout est
revenu très rapidement et là vous hanter
en forme parce que il faut dire que il
faut dire qu'au départ le le champion
d'europe était plutôt prévu au mois de
mars les choses se sont accélérées pour
une question de deux salles de liberté
de sa fin de celle qu'ils soient libres
donc s'était avancé au 19 février ce
n'était pas les plots que vous aviez
prévu au départ ça m'a effectivement
j'avais j'avais prévu de boxer en mars
donc avec une préparation plus longue là
il a fallu s'adapter donc on n'a pas le
choix c'est comme ça ça arrive
régulièrement dans le sport des dates
qui change des annulations surtout
depuis qu vite donc on fait avec mais de
toute façon on est toujours prêts dans
notre club on s'entraîne toute l'année
de façon intense au cas où il ya des
changements justement et puis ça vous
changera du dernier titre que vous avez
gagné parce que la dernière fois eh ben
il pouvait pas y avoir je crois de deux
personnes deux femmes de spectateurs 19
février à priori ça devrait marcher un
oui ou pour venir assister à leur
retrouver public absolument puis ça
correspond bien à votre devise soit quai
no time to ouest poteau à perdre on va
très très vite dès qu'on gagne un titre
on vise un autre titre de trois quatre
mois après c'est vrai que j'ai pas trop
le temps de nous reposer mais je me dis
je me reposerai après ma carrière après
2024 après 2024 c'est à dire après les
who oui c'est ça le fait alors il ya une
chose qui est assez étonnante c'est que
enfin qui peut paraître assez tôt
d'autres bois qui m'étonne quand même
c'est que c'est aux faux c'est vous qui
portez sur vos épaules le poids de
l'organisation de ce combat c'est là
qu'arrive où il faut trouver la salle
faut trouver faux faux faux avancer
l'argent
alors là la salle c'est tout c'est
souvent donc du coup la ville des
mureaux qui lui donne la salle et le
reste c'est c'est un autre charge c'est
à dire que comme pas aujourd'hui de
promoteurs qui prend en charge
l'événement on est devenus nous mêmes
notre on s'est lancé dans notre propre
promotion et chaque boxeur du coup à
doit aller chercher du budget chez les
sponsors chez les entreprises qui nous
sponsorisent pour effectivement réglés
tout le combat toute l'organisation donc
de base c'est pas comme ça que ça doit
se passer ce n'est pas notre travail
mais donc ça c'est l'inconvénient c'est
qu'on doit aller faire des choses qui ne
sont pas nos boulots mais l'avantagé
c'est un très grand avantage c'est que
ça nous permet de boxer régulièrement
quand on trouve les fonds de faire des
très belles soirées haut de gamme comme
on a pu faire sur les deux dernières du
coup les sponsors et les entreprises bas
y trouvent leur compte et tout le monde
est content donc c'est vrai que c'est un
peu dur d'aller tout le temps à la
recherche des budgets ça prend du temps
mais derrière le rendu est super quoi ça
nous permet d'avoir des gros titres et
aujourd'hui les autres clubs ne peuvent
pas se permettre de perdre et des titres
internationaux c'est des combats 20000
euros et nous on a décidé d'être un peu
culotté d'aller le faire nous-mêmes quoi
c'est ça et alors c'est vrai que mais
comme le comme le le le timing s'est un
peu accélérée c'est compliqué cela il
faut vous entraider faut aller chercher
des sponsors vous on est tous là vous
êtes vous avez encore besoin nom de
sponsor là celle-là c'est le rush les
journées à ça a trop vite parce que il
faut s'entraîner cinq heures par jour et
dans le peu de temps que j'ai donc de
repos
je dois couper le temps de repos en deux
pour passer mon temps au téléphone pour
parer aux entreprises pour chercher le
budget donc là il est toujours pas
clôturé le budget il manque 10 mille
euros et j'espère aller trouver parce
que le combat et dans trois semaines
mais j'y crois de traces on finit
toujours par y arriver mais voilà les
journées sont aussi autour de ça bah on
va lancer un appel aux entreprises aux
collectivités si voilà si vous voulez
sponsoriser ce combat qui va être grand
combat parce qu'il ya le titre de
championne d'europe et l'harmonie euros
chez nous d'un bureau vite c'est très
rare donc je pense aussi quand même il
ya un intérêt pour les autres parce que
déjà ça permet de communiquer sur les
valeurs du sport donc c'est une belle
image mon entreprise ça permet aussi
d'avoir des sportifs de haut niveau qui
interviennent en entreprise pour faire
des cours pour faire un partage de
parcours et travaille sur du cohésion
d'équipé team building donc il ya
toujours un intérêt pour les entreprises
de sponsoriser le les quartiers bas côté
on croise les doigts pour que vous ayez
vos petits budgets dont vous avez besoin
au croit évidemment les doigts pour
bourbon pour le combat va vous suivre et
il va vous soutenir et et danseurs on
sait tout votre talent ont donc on est
on est on a confiance en vous
ben j'espère revêt merci beaucoup ri
maya dis merci a bientot
[Musique]